SPEAKER 1: We got a brief
overview of service objects
last season.
But it's time to take a
deeper dive into services.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hiya, Kaslin.
It's good to see you.
I was just getting ready to
learn more about services.
Maybe you could help me out?
SPEAKER 2: Sure.
I remember how we
covered how services
were used to abstract away pod
lifecycle events last season.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
Because pods are
made to be started,
stopped, terminated,
and created.
But oftentimes,
applications need
to have a long-lived
or permanent address
to reach for interacting
with services.
SPEAKER 2: Yes.
So if you had a server back
end for storing images,
it might not matter which
pod serves the data back
to your front end.
But the front end
would always need
to know where to find your
back end to request pictures.
SPEAKER 1: And since each pod
gets its own IP address, that
would be a lot to manage,
storing an IP address whenever
a pod gets started or stopped.
So services exist to
store them for us,
making app development much
easier and more scalable.
But I remember we created
a special type of service
last time called a LoadBalancer.
What was that about?
SPEAKER 2: Well, see,
there's more than
just one type of service.
Depending on what
you're trying to do,
one may be more
suited to your needs.
But before that, let's go
into how to define services.
SPEAKER 1: If I
had a set of pods
that each listen
on TCP port 9376
and carry a label
app equals MyApp,
the YAML manifest file
would look like this.
This specification creates
a new service object
called my-service,
which targets TCP port
9376 on any pod with the
app equals MyApp label.
This is taking
traffic from port 9376
and routing it to the pod's
default port, port 80, which
greatly simplifies
app development.
Wait a minute.
What IP address
does a service have?
When I say it's getting
traffic from port 9376, that
must mean the service itself
gets an IP address, right?
SPEAKER 2: Right.
Kubernetes assigns this
service an IP address,
which is sometimes
called the ClusterIP.
And this brings us to the
first type of service,
the default ClusterIP type.
The ClusterIP
service type is only
reachable from other
points within the cluster.
We actually used these
before, last season,
to connect our front-end
service to the auth
and back-end services.
All of those were
running in Kubernetes.
So they just needed a cluster
IP to talk to each other.
SPEAKER 1: So then the next type
must be the LoadBalancer type
that we also used
in the last episode.
SPEAKER 2: Well, actually, no.
See, when you create a
LoadBalancer-type service,
you can see that it actually has
an internal ClusterIP address.
The LoadBalancer
service type also
uses what's called a NodePort
service underneath the hood.
SPEAKER 1: The
documentation says
a NodePort service exposes
a service on each node's
IP at a static point.
This type of service
also has a ClusterIP.
And to access it, you reference
the node IP NodePort address.
Um, please help me make sense
of why we'd want to do this?
SPEAKER 2: Great question.
You see, the LoadBalancer
type actually
uses NodePorts under the hood.
At some level, pods
are running on nodes.
So the only way
to access them is
by actually talking to
the machine they're on.
The difference is that
the LoadBalancer types
are pre-configured to use
a Cloud provider's load
balancer for you.
So if you're using
GKE on Google Cloud,
you'll be using Google
Cloud's load balancer
to distribute requests from your
service to your pod instances.
But what happens if
you're running on-prem,
and don't have a
Cloud-provided load balancer?
Or what about when you want to
roll your own load balancer?
SPEAKER 1: Oh.
In that case, I'd need to access
the NodePort myself, I guess.
SPEAKER 2: Exactly.
So we have ClusterIP services
for routing internal traffic,
NodePorts for allowing external
access to a specific port
on a specific machine,
and load balancers
for using Cloud-provided
LoadBalancer to route traffic
between the service's Pods.
SPEAKER 1: That's pretty robust.
Are there any other types?
SPEAKER 2: Well, there are more
advanced types of services,
like external name services
or headless services.
And there's even a
higher-level object
called ingress
objects that are used
to expose multiple services.
But I think we can save
those for another day.
SPEAKER 1: Many
thanks to Kaslin again
for continuing to drop
Kubernetes knowledge my way.
I'm excited to go play
with services more
and see what I can
create for myself.
For more information
about services,
please check out the
links in the description.